election's important we know in our
bones this one is more consequential
and this is the most important election
in the history of our country
[Music]
from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills between i'm so sorry i'm in new
york city here folks so we're getting a
little buzz at the door
uh but today we are talking about the
importance of
climate change and its impact on the
2020 election
between the president having coronavirus
protests over racial injustice
and wildfires raging across the west
coast there's a lot going
on but we're going to zero in on climate
change today and talk about how it might
impact voters when they cast their vote
on election day
joining us to discuss this and more is
jillian goodman a reporter for bloomberg
green
and carol horowitz the co-executive
director of the emma institute on
climate change in the environment at
ucla
thank you for joining us to start off
cara i want to go to you uh
we of course one of the major changes is
the death of ruth bader ginsburg leaving
a spot open on the supreme court can you
talk about
how that spot might impact the future
of climate legislation in the u.s sure
thanks for having me and thanks very
much so much for thinking about the
election from this angle i think it's
critically important
the death of justice ginsburg has really
highlighted the importance of the
supreme court
um for lots of issues that are critical
for this election and climate change is
just one of them
the role of administrative agencies in
regulating climate change is critical
agencies like
the environmental protection agency and
others
play a really important role when the
government tries to get a handle on a
problem like climate change
and the truth is with a 6-3 supreme
court
and a right-leaning judiciary the court
and the judiciary more generally are
likely to become more skeptical of
agency authority
what does that mean for climate change
it means that if
congress after the election tries to
enact new legislation that's more
aggressive in trying to control climate
change
it may face a more skeptical court in
its attempt to reign in this problem
um if a biden administration tries to
use epa
or other federal agencies to more
aggressively regulate climate pollution
again those efforts might face a more
skeptical supreme court
so everything just becomes more
difficult with the 63 court on in
climate change if what you're trying to
do is regulate climate pollution
and jillian going to you can you talk
about how the changes cara might
mentioned
could or just mentioned could impact
voters on election day
i mean i'm not a scholar of the supreme
court or even a scholar of the election
so it's hard for me to say
to talk about what voters might or may
not do with this in mind
um we do know that this has been a
particularly
salient issue for populations of color i
mean in your
introduction you talked about protests
over racial injustice
and this is fundamentally integrated
with the environment and climate change
you look at
communities of color are much more
likely to be impacted by pollution
they're also more likely to be impacted
by
um by climate change rising heat
rising sea levels etc they're also more
likely to
vote based on climate change they're
more likely to be concerned
about climate change polls show and so
you know
engaging that community uh you know
is really important when we're talking
about trying to get people to
vote in leaders who are going to be
mindful of climate change in the future
and jillian you bring up the importance
of the impact of climate change on
communities of color
cara i'm wondering if you have anything
else to add to that
well jillian is exactly right climate
change is an
inequality multiplier what i mean by
that is it's the most vulnerable
communities that are impacted
um earliest and hardest by climate
change we're talking about
elderly people we're talking about poor
people
communities of color there's a really
great example in california
you know over the last few weeks and
that stems from some of the wildfires
here that i think we may be talking
about in a bit
but during the periods of absolutely
terrible air quality when the air was
really toxic
and many families were being told to
stay in their homes all day long and not
to open their windows
our farm workers didn't have a choice
many of them are migrants many of them
are people of color they're poor
and they were out in the fields every
day having to pick our food
in that air that's just one you know
important
but small example of the way that in
climate change really harms the most
vulnerable communities
and that's not just true in the united
states it's true internationally
in the past i've worked with small
island developing states these are
really
small countries with small gdps that are
not in any way responsible for the
problem of climate change and they're
really facing
terrible effects of rising seas up to
and including the potential loss of
their countries
and so this is a dynamic as jillian says
that really drives people to vote in
those communities she's right that the
polling is that those communities
include some of the most passionate
supporters of strong climate action and
for good reason
and it's part i think of why we're
starting to see folks
in the environmental space and in the
democratic party
think about justice seriously when they
put together their climate plans
we're sticking with you oh jillian you
have anything to add to that well
yeah i just wanted to um i just wanted
to kind of make a distinction
here because when we talk about climate
change you know it is
a global issue it is a planetary scale
issue but then there's another
discussion of climate change that is
more focused
on these communities that we've been
discussing which involves
um pollution and the actual you know
like the water you drink and the air you
breathe
and these are you know whereas climate
change
uh on a global scale is much more
difficult for any one president to
influence these kinds of
local scale changes are going to be
something that are very much within the
next president's control
you know even when we're talking about
the court uh that confirmation
may well happen before election day so
either biden or trump
you know would be dealing with the same
court but these sort of but these more
local actions that really affect
the way people are going to be
interacting with their climate and the
climate that they are going to have
at home um again are going to be you
know are still very much in play
and you both mentioned uh the impact of
the wildfires on not only these
communities but also the outcome of this
election
can we hear from you jillian about how
both candidates have responded to these
fires and how that might impact voters
on election day
i mean you see the very clear
distinction
you know president trump uh who has
never
been let's say an activist in favor of
addressing climate change
talking again about forest management
whereas you have biden
uh acknowledging that these uh this is
inextricably linked to climate change
you can't talk about these fires without
talking about climate change
um and it really has underlined the
stark differences between these two
candidates when it comes to
uh even just the the fundamental
acknowledgement of climate change let
alone the policies
um for what we intend to do about it
and cara something that we spoke about
uh in preparation for this interview
was just what it's like to sort of cover
these issues
uh while we have a president who
is maybe casting doubt about the truth
surrounding climate change can you talk
about what that experience has been like
for you personally
sure sure i live in california um and
like so many of my
colleagues neighbor neighbors community
members
um we've now lived through a really
tragic month
of wildfires that have been
unprecedented in scale at just this
morning we got news that our one of our
wildfires has now reached a million
acres in size which is
a mind-blowing number we've now
burned up more than four million acres
in the state which is
a size larger than the state of
connecticut you can just imagine if
something on the scale was happening on
the east coast what kind of attention it
would be getting from our national
lawmakers and um it's not just the fires
we've all been living with
incredibly poor air quality as i said
that have kept
families indoors you know afraid to send
their kids
outside obscuring the sky and the sun
it's just
unbelievable and then in the face of all
of this in the midst of all this we have
a presidential leader who comes
and talks to our beleaguered you know
state leaders and says that he thinks
the science doesn't know
it's hard to know what to do with that i
mean it just doesn't reflect
the facts um i i'm friends with lots of
climate scientists
they will clearly tell you the science
does know
there are two times as many extreme fire
days in california in the fall than
there used to be because of climate
change
it's clear climate change is making this
worse so to have
yeah i'm a relatively mild-mannered law
professor i run a nonpartisan research
institute at ucla i have
lots of friends who i love and respect
who are republicans but it's hard to
know what to do when
one political party continuously just
buries its head
in the sand on these important issues
jillian what has that experience been
like for you
you know just as cara said it's
uh there is one side that acknowledges
what is actually
happening and one side that does not
and it's you know it's simply the truth
um and it's a difficult thing to wrap
your head around
as a journalist um and
you know the all of journalism has been
dealing with this
for the last you know since well before
the 2016 election that the problems of
of misinformation and political
misinformation and those you know
political misinformation is not confined
to one party like both
both sides are guilty of various
untruths over the years but the
persistent
failure um of the republican party to
acknowledge climate change let alone
pass responsible legislation
to help us deal with it either you know
on a citizenry level
within the us uh and on an international
level
um with the rest of the international
community you see
uh the eu is blazing past us
china i think it was two weeks ago
committed to going carbon neutral
by 2060 um which has huge geopolitical
implications so we're
we're really behind on dealing with this
one thing we've talked about quite a bit
is trump's response to climate change
but i also want to hear from both of you
about
biden's plans to address the climate
crisis um
his proposal will take up the portions
of the green new deal has
alienated both some moderate right
voters and some
far left voters jillian can you talk
about that distinction and the
challenges biden has faced
um trying to get both groups to vote for
him
sure i mean so far he's been reasonably
successful
in bringing uh two sides to the climate
table that haven't traditionally been
there at the same time
um you have the climate activists and
people who are arguing for aggressive
energy transition policies and an
aggressive net zero timeline
and on the other hand you have um unions
which work on things like oil rigs and
you know at natural gas wells
and uh don't want to see their jobs
go away because of aggressive climate
policy
and the biden plan you know as you say
it's managed to upset
people on either end of the spectrum by
uh you know committing to a net zero
goal but also
not committing to things like banning
fracking
uh joe biden has been very pro natural
gas
as a transition as a bridge fuel is the
is the term that that's held over from
the obama years
um to make sure that we that people are
in jobs and that we have energy as we
work to transition in the united states
to uh solar and wind and other renewable
forms of energy
um whether or not that's necessary you
know i think a lot of people a lot of
climate scientists would say that we
don't need
natural gas as a bridge fuel which is
why they're upset um
but uh it'll be it'll be removed elected
to see
how that plays out uh the plan is the
most aggressive
climate plan we've seen of any
presidential candidate ever
democrat or republican but that of
course is
a campaign you know sales pitch it's not
policy yet so there's a long way to go
cara how folks within the climate expert
community reacted to biden's plan
yeah so just as jillian says it's clear
biden's trying to walk a pretty
fine line but to my view and i think to
the view of a lot of folks in my world
he's walked it fairly successfully he
incorporated
significant elements of sort of the more
left-leaning climate plans
from camps like warrens and inslees
and crafted a climate plan that includes
significant mandates for getting to
clean electricity and
net zero carbon clean electricity by
2035 which polls show voters are really
in favor of
to do so in a way that creates lots of
jobs which is of course an important
part of the conversation in any economy
but especially this one
it includes significant elements of
public investment
over two trillion dollars um and you
know pays attention to those
equity and justice questions we
discussed earlier in the
program and so i think he's done a
fairly good job bringing
the kind of left more left wing of the
party along
and uh jillian's right this is the most
aggressive
climate plan we've seen from any
democratic major
candidate ever i think it's critically
important to recognize
the fundamental difference between the
biden camp and the trump camp on these
issues which is that biden takes this
problem seriously has pledged to retake
the mantle of international leadership
and would be headed in you know the
right direction
maybe not quickly enough but at least
you know
toward the right goal line whereas
whereas trump would and
most voters recognize that fundamental
difference even if they're not
entirely on all four squares with biden
on every detail
and before we wrap i just want to ask
both of you why you think this is the
most important election
ever uh starting with you jillian what
are your thoughts on that oh i get to go
first
uh i you know we were prepared that this
would be a question
to sound can because it is um but uh
you know the ipcc in 2018 gave us until
2050
to zero out our carbon emissions or face
uh irreversible climate consequences
we have 30 years left to do that and
four is a big chunk
when you're talking about 30 years so uh
the next four years will be you know
absolutely determinative
of where we come out on that goal and
where we come out um
as a planet
cara what are your thoughts on that
yeah i think of this less as a question
of political science and more as a
question
of math like do we want a stable
climate do you know i have a 10 year old
and a 13 year old what kind of world do
i want them to live in
do i want my communities to feel safe
do i want my president to be protecting
my public health
as opposed to sort of enacting the wish
list of the fossil
fuel industry these are the things that
are at stake and
um the next you know five to ten years
will help us determine
whether we reach those goals i don't
think
it's i i don't really want to live in a
world where
we wait another 10 years to work on
these issues because
it'll get more expensive and lots more
people will suffer
jillian and cara thank you so much both
of you for joining us today for those of
you watching please continue to follow
bloomberg quick take on all social
platforms wherever you get your news
and thank you so much again for making
time to watch today
thanks so much thank you